[Music]
now here's a fella who makes grown women
lose their minds we're talking about
Charlie Hunnam you know Nancy he packed
on 20 pounds of muscle to play King
Arthur and that transformation really
made all of the difference as easy
outlines lauren zima
found out looking at Charlie's chiseled
abs it's kind of hard to believe
director Guy Ritchie initially didn't
want the Sons of Anarchy start to play
the sword wielding legend I'd lost an
enormous amount of weight for the last
season the sons so I showed up very very
skinny and he wanted someone who was
sort of physically imposing for the role
Charlie was up against some well-known
actors for this take on the medieval
tale so to convince guy he threw down a
challenge I said why don't you just
bring them all in here and we'll fight
and whoever walks out the room gets the
role and and I think that's the moment
he's sort of like that Moxie I saw I've
got a little twinkle as I said I Charlie
reportedly beat out x-men's Michael
Fassbender and one of them wears a cape
oh Henry Cavill okay maybe how intense
was the training and what was the
hardest part about it it's maintaining
the diet you know because you just don't
get to you all the fun things you want
to eat and also eating an enormous
amount coz this is my natural body size
I'm pretty skinny guy one person not
impressed with those muscles his
girlfriend of 11 years jewelry designer
Morgana McNellis she thinks it's a bit
silly you know when I get really big it
says that it she says it makes her feel
really small so like I'm looking skinny
yeah Micah Farris exactly so she I think
she likes it in that regards but in
terms of you know we've been together so
long it's like put your muscles away
come to bed you know
[Music]
you